um eyeballs rats bats vampire teeth boom
vampire teeth good
spiderwebs done fake blood capsules
oh they didn't have any really
that's gross i love it daddy's daughter
anna's getting divorced
i hate to say i told you so but i told
you so
you know we should fix her up with
bernice's
son what's his name the doctor oh vince
and he's not a doctor he's a pharmacist
although that might appeal to anne pop
craig you're such a cracker
forget anne who should we fix him up
with huh oh now sal you know i'm still
getting over the tragedy loss of my wife
she was such a strong female woman with
nice heavy breasts
who's that oh that's my neighbor
hey larry ah hey
grab greg ah that was it i'm not sure
why i have so much trouble remembering
probably because our relationship is so
casual
morning ladies hi uh do a lap without me
i need to talk to larry about an issue
with our shared fence larry
i need to talk to you about an issue
with our shared fence yes i also need to
discuss this
shared fence issue with you okay they're
out of earshot
why are you up so early no reason just
excited to face a new day
oh because ever since we've been down
here you've been a little
depressed have i i
don't eat the burrito
[Music]
oh god needs numbers
okay whoa god yuck yuck yuck
wow what happened in there i don't know
there's a stink in there
my god what it what is that
oh i don't know is that a bird i don't
think it's a bird
oh god how could that happen how
could right in the middle of the carpet
what's going on
um somebody vomited right in the middle
of the carpet in my office
i don't think that's vomit check it out
me
check it out
don't be a wuss just get known holding
your coffee
tell me what it is oh that's really good
what is it
michael what is it no just tell me what
it is michael i i got to get out of here
i can't hold my breath that long open
the door up
it smelled terrible
oh oh
i cannot believe a pipe burst and left
that there there's no burst pipe
how do you know that what is it then hey
guys somebody making soup
so we've been called out to this hiking
trail because there's some reports that
some teenagers
are digging bags of dog poop out of the
trash and having dog boot fights
i don't believe it
oh my god it's real uh yeah i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna go deal with this i'm
leaving
hey hey hello
boys i am leslie knope i work for the
department of parks and recreation
okay
oh smells so bad oh why would you think
this was fun
oh really oh really really oh hey hey
you like it
okay here we go who wants it
actually this is a little fun this is
fun
welcome to the jimmy jabs we play for
pride
we play for the phone numbers of rosa's
friends but most importantly
we play to watch amy lose nope this is
my year
it's my year too please don't align
yourself with me why not neither of you
have ever come
close to winning you're exactly the same
just a couple of santiagos
but the real prize is the winchester
3000
the only chair in the precinct with
minimal staining good lumbar support
and no broken rolly wheels over to you
gina
thank you jake okay guys as usual the
loser of each event
is eliminated from the games the winner
gets a bonus in the final round
our first event is the mouth-a-thon
in front of you is month-old chinese
food from the fridge
go ahead and eat as much as you can
stomach
on your mark get set wahlberg
[Music]
oh i can't do this to my mouth
she's the love of my life charles is
eliminated
off i think this ball of soup is off i'm
out i can do this
i want to win so bad oh great here quick
let me take a picture
oh that's so cute you've got a little
bit of mold on the tip of your nose
i tried i tried but he is unbeatable
you guys know this is free right i'm
sorry you guys have probably noticed my
stomach's a little more sensitive lately
so if you wouldn't mind wearing a little
less perfume
and if your lunch is especially pungent
maybe have it in the break room
we would really appreciate it pam is
constantly throwing up because of the
pregnancy
if she eats something the fetus doesn't
like she is screwed
it's amazing a three ounce fetus is
calling the shots
it's so badass phyllis
um if you could switch to a different
soap just for a month or two
yours is kind of perfumy now this is
getting ridiculous
oh gee i'm sorry i guess i missed the
meeting where we all voted for you to
get pregnant
no i reserve the right to peel my
hard-boiled eggs at my desk
all morning i look forward to my
afternoon cigars and i am not stopping
for
anybody i don't think i'm asking for too
much
i guess it's just the end of courtesy in
the workplace
watching people get sick always makes me
sick
and frankly soda's talking about it so
wow
ah
jerry god gross
oh jerry guys
oh god oh i think he might be having a
heart attack what
are you serious oh so much stuff is
happening right now call 9-1-1
okay okay just breathe okay you're gonna
be fine no
jeez did a dinosaur just fart jerry get
a grip sorry guys
[ __ ] apology not accepted stop talking
[ __ ]
i wish i could stop smelling dude
seriously jerry did you eat farts for
lunch
tom jerry's having a heart attack oh no
i didn't know that
jerry you okay scully
where are you on digitizing the old case
files as of yesterday i'm officially one
percent done
why are you smiling that's nothing oh
there's thousands of cases and for each
one i have to fill out 200 little box
thingies on 50 different screens at
least you get to sit on your butt all
day
that's actually the worst part my doctor
said i have an anal canyon
oh scully why are you always telling us
about your disgusting body
i don't see anything that's because it's
all wort
that's interesting wow it's a little
early for ice cream nowadays it's never
too early for ice cream jim
but we didn't have any ice cream so this
is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
god michael this old donna thing is
gonna be okay you just
stop beating yourself up i know well i
hope you're right we'll see what dwight
says
why do we have to see what dwight says
because i have him investigating her i'm
waiting for a text up
michael no no no no no no undo that undo
that
it's too late to undo it i need to know
otherwise this thing is going to spiral
out of a muck
michael okay i'm i'm going to talk
straight to you
because i think you need to hear it
michael this is so disgusting stop
eating it
you